l'organe de règlement des différends au
sein de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce
du fait des tensions commerciales que
nous traversons et avec la paralysie
cet organe d'appel l'union européenne
doit être donc en capacité de mieux
défendre ses intérêts c'est l'objet
d'une farce m et c'est pas liées
justement ces difficultés avec des
propositions qui sont ambitieuses
notamment avec les mesures provisoires
le règlement and the huntsman c'est une
proposition de la commission sur le
respect et l'application des règles en
matière commerciale
je suis rapporteur pour le parlement
européen sur ce question qui permet en
fait à l'union européenne de mieux
défendre ses intérêts
ce règlement c'est une position
ambitieuse que je souhaite porter doter
l'union européenne d'outils juridiques
qui lui permettent de se défendre de
manière efficace et de manière cohérente
c'est pour ça que j'ai souhaité élargir
le champ proposée par la commission
européenne
en incluant les services et les droits
de la propriété intellectuelle et en
proposant les fameuses mesures
provisoires les mesures provisoires
c'est quoi ces d'une ambition que j'ai
souhaité porter au sein de ce rapport
c'est donner la capacité l'union
européenne de mieux se défendre de créer
un instrument dysphasie quand un état
tiers impose des mesures unilatérales
l'union européenne doit être en capacité
de se défendre dès l'ouverture d'un
panel ce sont les mesures provisoires